researchers from oxford university in  england have new data now regarding  those rare cases of blood clots  in coba 19 patients and vaccine  recipients both astrazeneca  and johnson and johnson have had very  rare reports of blood clots related to  their vaccines  you'll remember the u.s has now paused  johnson and johnson vaccines to further  investigate  this new data shows that getting covet  has higher risks  than getting the vaccine the importance  of this fight is it brings it back to  the fact this is a really horrible  illness  has a whole variety of effects including  increased risk of cvt  and pvt in this group researchers say  the  new data highlights the benefits of  getting the vaccine  still outweigh the risks of getting  cover 19.